Ba ba ba ba. Wie ging eure Schulglocke? Ba ba ba ba. Wirklich jetzt? Wirklich? So eine Schule hast du besucht? Die amerikanische High School? Dam dam dam dam dam dam dam dam dam dam dam Pause. Ihr habt jetzt fünf Minuten Pause. Also wenn ihr gerade alle in der U-Bahn euch umgeguckt habt, wer gerade auch diesen Gong vervollständigt hat, der ist ein Podcast-UFO-Hörer. Sagt doch mal hallo. Bringt euch mal zu, wir brauchen noch immer diese geheimen Handzeichen wie die Welle, weißt du, wir brauchen dieses, aber das ist echt uncool. Da wir jetzt so eine faschistische Gruppe geworden sind, ist diese Welle immer noch echt uncool. Gab es das jetzt eigentlich wirklich oder nicht? Weiß ich doch nicht. Dieser Film Das Experiment, wo die alle so eine faschistoide Gemeinschaft gründen, um den Leuten zu zeigen. Niemand weiß, ob es das gibt. Wie dumm müssen die Schüler sein, um da nicht rauszufallen. Ah, ihr glaubt nicht, dass Deutsche zu Nazis werden konnten? Na, komisch, dass wir dieses neue Projekt, wo wir alle irgendwie in Gruppen eingeteilt werden, genau gestaltet haben, nachdem der Lehrer gesagt hat, wie ihr glaubt nicht, dass sowas auch bei euch passieren kann. Kommt euch das nicht komisch vor? Du bist ein Verräter, du bist oder ein... Vor allem was für eine komische Situation, dass alle unfähige Leute dumme Leute waren. Ich meine, die von hatten die keine Mathe mehr oder was? Die Meinung zu vertreten, dass es nicht normal passieren wird und so, ist ja einfach doof. Hatten die keine Mathe oder was? Ja genau, haben die die ganze Zeit, ne die haben auch schon normal Unterricht gehabt dann noch. Hörst du das? Nein, ich habe meinen Bart ein bisschen wachsen lassen. Und du rasiert, du hast rasiert. Heißt, wir treffen uns irgendwann in der Mitte. Ich nehme mir zu und habe mein Bart wachsen lassen.
Ich muss da ganz kurz eine Cashew-Kern-Essen.
Vor allem, es sind Cashews und Cranberries. Welcher wahnsinnige, sagen wir mal, was für ein wahnsinniges Genie ist auf diese Idee gekommen, das zu kreuzen.
Es ist nämlich perfekt. Manchmal denke ich mir, ich habe nämlich auch mal eine Limonade selber gemacht und da habe ich noch Ingwer hinzugefügt. Da dachte ich mir, what? War natürlich nicht meine Idee, sondern auch ebenfalls, ich glaube sogar von dem gleichen Genie. Da ist irgendwer auf die Idee gekommen, herauszuschmecken, was fehlt für einen Geschmack und dann aus dem anderen Spektrum noch was hinzugefügt. Ich glaube, das ist ganz mathematisch. Die Kranbeere, klassische Kranbeere und Cashews treffen schon ganz gut. Ich glaube, das ist wie Musik. Das ist schon was Subjektives, aber ich glaube, da ist ein ganz Hardcore-wissenschaftlicher Grund dahinter.
Du hast ja die fünf verschiedenen Geschmacksfarben. Big Mac, Big Mac, Whopper, Apfeltasche und Süssauer. Und daraus setzt man sich dann so alles so zusammen. Dann muss es sein. Das ist wie ein grosses Spektrum. Gibt es auch Komplementärgeschmäcker von einem anderen Spektrum? Passen die dann ganz besonders gut zusammen oder passen die dann gar nicht gut zusammen? Schlecht zusammen, weiß ich nicht. Oder halt so süss und herr. Unser Biolehrer damals hatte keine Zunge. Also die Zunge war noch da, aber die Geschmacksleffen hat er verloren, weil er hat seinen Geruchssinn verloren. Der ist nämlich als Kind ganz auf seine Nase gefallen, glaube ich. Und da sind dann die Geschmackszellen verbunden mit der Zunge und der Nase. Das merkt man auch manchmal, wenn man sehr krank ist und die Nase zusitzt, schmeckt man nicht mehr. Das habe ich schon ganz oft gehabt. Und der hat nie geschmeckt. Das Einzige, was er noch geschmeckt hat, war bitter. Und das denke ich mir, das ist doch die Hölle. Der isst einfach ein Schnitzel und es schmeckt bitter. Aber wie oft muss man auf die Nase fallen, damit die Geschmackszellen sagen,, Leute, ey, wenn ihr uns nicht um mich kümmern, dann sind wir raus. Wir sind hier raus, die Arbeitsbedingungen sind furchtbar, die ganze Zeit läuft der Gegend scheiß Baum. Ja, und vor allem war das dann ein laufender Prozess, wo man sagt, hm, irgendwie, je häufiger ich auf die Nase falle, dass du weniger schmecke, ich sollte aufhalten. Versuche ich es nochmal. Der Effekt der Woche, möchte ich kurz ankündigen, oh Mann, jetzt habe ich die ganze Zeit so Nussstücke im Mund. Ja. Der Effekt der Woche, möchte ich kurz ankündigen, jetzt habe ich die ganze Zeit so Nussstücke im Mund. Der Effekt der Woche. Ich war wieder auf der Suche nach einem Effekt, ich möchte euch einen neuen Effekt präsentieren. Und den Effekt, den ich euch diese Woche vorstellen möchte, ist der Lazarus-Effekt. Stefan Tietze, was ist der Lazarus-Effekt? Das ist der Effekt, dass wenn du zu nah an die Sonne fliegst, du merkst, je näher du an die Sonne fliegst, desto mehr merkst du, dass du keine Ahnung hast, wer Lazarus eigentlich ist, und dann verbrennst du an der Sonne. Völlig richtig, 100 Punkte für Stefan Tietze. Dankeschön. Lazarus-Effekt. A hat was mit Zeitreisen zu tun, B hat was mit Tieren zu tun, C hat was mit Gebäuden zu tun, mir fällt diese neue Quizrichtung nicht die Beeinträchtigung. Oder d hat was mit Essen zu tun, oder e, dieses Format ist jetzt schon so gut wie tot, falsch, Tiere. Richtig, das ist die neue Rubrik, der Effekt der Woche. Ein bisschen interaktiv, Leute. Wenn ihr die Antworten wissen, schreibt. Ja, erklär doch jetzt mal. Der letzte Ressens ist der Effekt, dass wenn man ein Tier, von dem man dachte, es sei ausgestorben, es aber dann doch nochmal findet. Und wann kann man das anwenden im Alltag? Es gibt tatsächlich eine Liste von ausgestorbenen Tieren. Der hast du dir nicht ausgedacht, oder was? Nein, es gibt eine Liste von Tieren, die ausgestorben waren und dann doch wieder gefunden wurden. Das stimmt doch. Wie geil ist das denn? Sowohl Pflanzen als auch Tiere. Totgeglaubte leben länger. Es gibt auch eine Liste von Prominenten, die schon mal als Tod für tot erklärt wurden. Und Leute wirklich, hier Emma Watson, die wurde schon mal für tot erklärt für einen Tag, Taylor Lautner, wo ich damals als Twilight-Fan dachte, was? Du siehst so ein bisschen aus wie Taylor Lautner. Echt jetzt? Ich glaube, wenn du ein bisschen trainieren würdest und ein bisschen Solarium gehen würdest, hättest du diesen Taylor-Lortner-Blick. Aber dann wäre das schon ein bisschen... Ganz enge Augen, ganz zusammen. Ich habe winzige Augen. Du hast auch kaum Raumsicht, weil die beiden sich fast lecken eigentlich vom Schifffeld. Ja, genau. Ich sehe auch ein bisschen breitbildlich, weil ich habe so sehr schmale Augen. Du hast auch Bild im Bild, ne? Ich glaube, die meisten sehen so 16 zu 9 ungefähr. Bei mir ist es eher so 1 zu 2,7 sowas. So ein klassisches Kino-Breitbildformat. Ja. Es ist ganz schwer zu sagen, welche Form sein Sichtfeld hat. Ist es ein Oval? Sind es zwei Ovale? Ich glaube, es ist fast, ja, oh. Ich würde es eher einen Grad angeben, weil es ja schon, du siehst ja auch, du hast ja auch peripheres Sehen rechts und links. Wenn du mal deine Hände ganz schnell bewegst, wenn ihr alle mal kurz eure Hände hochnehmt, sie neben euren Kopf haltet, wie ein grosses, also wenn ihr den Fernseher darstellen wolltet und dann eure Hände nach vorne bewegt ganz schnell, dann, so erkennt ihr jetzt gerade übrigens die anderen Podcast-Hoförer und ihr seht, dass ihr noch peripheres Sehen habt. Und wenn ihr das alle in der U-Bahn macht, dann hebt ihr vielleicht ab. Was war das denn? Die U6? Die U6! Tschüss U6! Auf den Weg. Was gibt's Neues aus der Welt der Stefan T? Stefan T hat keine neue Phase eingeschlagen, er ist weiterhin bei sich in so einer komischen Zwischenwelt gefangen. Nee, ich bin jetzt in so einer Flugzeugphase. Tatsächlich hat YouTube jetzt quasi, es veranschaulicht mir bildlich, was ich für eine Phase habe. Weil, achtet mal drauf, wenn ihr eingeloggt seid, einen Account habt und regelmäßig Videos guckt, dann werden euch irgendwann nicht nur Abonnenten eure Abonnements vorgeschlagen, die neuen Videos von den Beans, neuen Videos von Good Arbeit Originals, nein, sondern irgendwann werden halt auch Themengebiete vorgeschlagen. Themengebiet Formel 1. Jetzt habe ich ein Themengebiet Flugzeug, weil ich zwei Flugzeugvideos angeschaut habe, weil ich das cool fand, Emergency Landings, weil mittlerweile ist es sehr gut dokumentiert. Und wenn Leute Emergency haben und dann fallen diese Westen runter, fangen Leute einfach an zu filmen, was natürlich grossartig ist für Leute wie mich, die dann mal so eine Situation miterleben können. Wie cool ist das denn? Und die Crew stellt sich heraus, ist immer total aufgebracht und nervös, halt so wie man denkt, bitte seid niemals aufgebracht und nervös. Die Crew ist immer so, läuft immer durch die und dann helfen die wirklich erst sich selber, dann den Kindern, habe ich auch gesehen in diesem Video. Also Leute machen das wirklich. Und dann sieht man auch rechts das Triebwerk in Flammen und Notwasserungen und so ein Bullshit. Kann man alles mittlerweile bei YouTube angucken. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Wie viele davon gibt es denn da so pro Jahr? Nein, nicht so viele, oder? Gar nicht so viele, nee. Was cool ist, war dieser JetBlue-Vorfall, wo vorne das Vorder-Schnauze? Nee, wie heißtisst das denn? Gear, das Frontgear. Fahrwerk. Fahrwerk, das Frontfahrwerk hat sich verkeilt und konnte nicht wieder reingezogen werden. War dann quasi quer, startet das dann. Und es musste landen auf diesem Queren und die wussten nicht, ob das Flugzeug wieder vorne überkippt vielleicht so oder nicht bremsen kann. Und das wussten die halt auch. Und deswegen haben die die Landung, haben Filmteams gefilmt, weil die wussten, was gleich passiert. Und die Leute innen drin haben auch gefilmt. Ganz spannend. Und das Bordprogramm, der Film wird unterbrochen. Wo ich mir auch immer dachte, ich will nicht zu Hermine Granger sterben, die da irgendwie gerade mit Victor Krumm tanzt. Und dann läuft da irgendwie Harry Potter im Fernsehen und ich will da nicht dabei sterben. Nee, es geht einfach aus und dann kommt so eine Warnmeldung. Das ist nicht schlecht. Ja, das ist gut. Wir müssen aber nochmal, also wir müssen, wir sind ja auch so ein bisschen Improver. Wir wollen die Gesellschaft verbessern, wir wollen unsere, das Podcast-Ufo-Mission, falls ihr uns mal wieder sprechen wollt oder Artikel über uns schreiben wollt, unsere einzige Mission ist eigentlich, euch das Leben besser zu machen, das Leben zu analysieren und zu gucken, wie kann man das besser machen. Service-Podcast. Wir haben nicht unbedingt immer den besten Tipp, wie das besser ist. Wir machen auch manchmal, zeigen wir nur auf Fehler und machen auf die aufmerksam. Und ich möchte darauf aufmerksam machen, dass beim Fliegen nicht geklärt ist, ob es gesellschaftlich erlaubt ist, den Sitz zurückzumachen. Weil ich habe mich überobachtet auf dem Hinflug zum Malediven. Echt, du warst auf dem Malediven? Ja, ganz toll, muss ich mal in der Folge erzählen. Da waren Drochen und Wahnsinn, tolle Tiere. Und dann bin ich da hingeflogen und vor mir waren Frauen und Kind und die waren super nervig, super anstrengend, haben die ganze Zeit auch gemeckert und haben das Essen zurückgeben lassen, wo ich mir denke, was erwartet ihr in dem Flugzeug für ein Essen und haben sofort die Sitze zurückgemacht. bin ich in Sekunde zehn des Fluges, wo diese Lampen aus waren, die Sitze, auch ohne zu fragen.
Und ich habe haltunde zehn des Fluges, wo diese Lampen aus waren, die Sitze, auch ohne zu fragen.
Und ich habe halt gerade dann Larry David, Curb Your Enthusiasm geguckt und dann in dem Moment ging der Sitze zurück. Ich denke mir, what? Und dann habe ich diese Musik von Larry David, ging er an und dachte mir, ja, das ist genau so eine Situation gerade. Und ich war kurz davor, was zu sagen. Ähm, auch, es ist glaube ich auch noch ein Unterschied, ob du jetzt dich umdrehst, fragst, ist es kurz okay, wenn ich den Sitz zurück mache und dann langsam zurück mache, so sorry mit diesem Blick, mit diesem entschuldigenden Blick, oder ob du einfach ohne zu fragen einfach bumm nach hinten knallst, den Laptop hinter dir fast zum Einsturz bringen. Lass das mal durchgehen. Ich meine, dieses Umerlaubnis fragen ist für mich eine Far dass du sagst ... Du machst den Anschein eines gesellschaftlichen Diskurses zumindest.
Ja, aber niemand würde jemals sagen nein.
Aber das ist doch gut.
Aber damit nimmst du deinem Hintermann die Möglichkeit, sich zu ärgern.
Und das ist eigentlich das eigentliche Verbrechen.
Wenn du ein Arschloch bist, musst du deinem Hintermann die Möglichkeit geben,
dass er in seinem Podcast die ICE-Story erzählen kann, wie so ein Arschloch, so ein langer Arschloch mit Bermuda-Hose und Rochenhut sich da irgendwie zurückgelehnt hat. Die gab es umsonst am Flughafen. Und ein Flugzeug ruiniert hat. Das finde ich ist wichtig. Und schön finde ich auch dieses, ja sorry, das passiert jetzt halt. Tut mir leid. Ja, und mit diesem angespitzten Mundwinkel und so ein bisschen Zähne zeigen.
Und dann habe ich Folgendes gemacht.
Ich habe mir auch ein Nackenkissen gekauft, zum ersten Mal.
Ich war mal Kontra-Nackenkissen, nicht mehr als Pro-Nackenkissen.
Nackenkissen ist eigentlich eine tolle Sache.
Man muss herausfinden, wie es funktioniert.
Ich habe den ersten Hintflug, habe ich mich rumgeräkelt, um herauszufinden, wie es funktioniert.
Rückflug habe ich dann herausgefiggert.
Aber der erste Flug, da habe ich mich aufgeregt. Der Sitz kam zurück, ich war stocksauer, stocksauer. Und zurück, der Rückflug hat jemand vor mir wieder den Sitz zurückgemacht und ich habe ihn sofort auch zurückgemacht.
Ja, das ist halt der Domino-Effekt. Und es war der beste Flug, den ich habe die ganze Zeit den Sitz zurückgemacht und es war der beste Flug.
Und ich denke mir, okay, selbst in meinem Kopf ist es nicht klargeklärt.
Was darf man, was darf man nicht? Darf man sich aufregen?
Darf man der Stewart erst sagen, Entschuldigung, der hat jetzt schon seit zehn Minuten den Sitz runtergemacht. Ja, viel später, holst du Mutti und dann hast du eine sehr unangenehme Situation. Ich frage mich wirklich, also da sollte man was klären vernünftig. Also entweder, die haben diese Funktion eingebaut, man kann den Sitz zurück machen, manche werben sogar mit manchen Airlines, dass man den Sitz weiter zurück machen kann. Dann denke ich mir, okay. So ein Bild von so einer glücklichen Person, die nach hinten liegt und die Person dahinter, wirklich so komplett genervt. Immer saurer. Und je saurer die Person, desto besser die Airline, what? Und dann denke ich mir auch, also klärt das jetzt mal bitte, sagt, ist es okay? Und dann kann man zwischendurch sagen, dass oben so ein Anschnallzeichen auch für das Rückmachzeichen erscheint, sondern dass es die Tür desmal sagt, okay, ganz kurz, es ist jetzt gesellschaftlich akzeptiert, dass alle kurz ihren Sitz zurückmachen, weil dann haben alle genug Platz. Weil du bist auch nicht das Arschloch, weil hinter dir, wenn vor dir das jemand macht und du machst es deswegen, dann kannst du ja blamen auf den Vordermann von dir. Das ist eine ganz interessante Metapher für gesellschaftliche Prozesse, weißt du, wenn du von oben immer nur Ärger kriegst, dann gibst du dir nach unten weiter und am Ende sitzt der Typ, der ganz hinten sitzt, der nicht nach hinten machen kann und das ist halt die Unterschicht.
Ja, aber Flugzeug ist halt auch Diktatur, weil die haben oben halt diese Anzeiger, weißt du? Das zeichnet eine Diktatur aus, dass die oben so Anzeiger haben? Ja, ne, eine Metapher, die ist jetzt nicht mitgegangen, diesen Schritt, den ich die Transferliste und nicht von dir erwartet hätte.
Die Anzeigen von oben sind natürlich ganz klare Befehle.
In dem Moment, wo die Anzeigen ausgehen, hört man doch das Klackern. Und die Leute stürmen zum Bathroom. Und in dem Moment, wo oben so ein jetzt könnt ihr den Sitz zurück machen, entscheiden würde, würden alle das sofort machen und sich gut fühlen. Was sagst du zu den Händen auf Lehne? Passiert bei mir tatsächlich oft beim Zugfahren, dass jemand die Hände oben über seinen Kopf auf die eigene Lehne des Hitzes legt, so dass der Hintermann wirklich die Fingernägel im Gesicht hat. Ja, kitzeln, sofort instant kitzeln. Und da habe ich tatsächlich gemacht, so ganz leicht anpusten. Ganz leicht anpusten, bis die Person irgendwann es wegnimmt. Und du weißt nicht genau ... Aufstoßen, aufstoßen und anpusten, das ist das Beste. Ja, oder halt der klassische Niestrick, einfach dreimal ordentlich drauf niesen auf die Hände.
Oder so rum unten einen Rucksack nochmal hochholen, damit die Haare immer so kontinuierlich an die Hände kommen.
Oder das Essen so dran schmieren.
Nee, weißt du, das ist ein Problem.
Und ich hatte mal auf dem Flug nach New York, er war neben mir ein Holländer. Und das sage ich, weil das ebenfalls das grösste Volk der Erde ist. Durchschnittlich sind das die grössten Menschen. Und rechts neben mir das grösste Volk der Erde. Oder ich dachte, das grösste Volk. Master Race, ach so. Wirklich, hast du die Fakten da? Kurz so eine Stirnrunzeln, aber du hast mich auch nicht unterbrochen. Du hast es kurz geglaubt. Ich guck mal, wo er damit hingeht. Ja, ja, und rechtzeitig war er auch ein sehr großer, ebenfalls in meinem Alter, ein Jünger in meinem Alter, und das war echt unangenehm, weil er ähnlich wie ich verfahren ist, nämlich Toilettenpausen nutzen, um Fußraum und Armraum einzunehmen. Also in dem Moment, wo man kurz eine Unaufmerksamkeit ausnutzen, er war kurz in seinem Rucksack oben, direkt ausgebreitet, direkt so ausgefahren, wie das Flugzeug so Landeklappen ausfährt, direkt ein bisschen expandiert und dann, das musst du so stückweise machen, peu a peu. Es ist ein Kampf, es ist ein Aussitz. Ein Flugzeug ist Krieg. Es ist ein Aussitzen. Ja, ne und dann neuerdings hängt mir YouTube deswegen die ganzen Flugzeugsachen an. Das ist auch, und dann denke ich mir, ja gut, man weiss bei mir nicht, was zuerst da war, das Interesse oder dass jemand mir das Interesse aufprojiziert quasi. Aber ich fände so ein Evaluationsgespräch ganz gut mit so einem Stewardess-Team, dass dann irgendwie so, genau, wir haben ja in der Ausbildung gesagt, wenn was passiert, ruhig bleiben, den Leuten helfen, wir gucken mal ganz kurz ins Video rein. Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott, gib die Nisse, Geben Nisse, ich spreche aus! Das ist doch nie passiert! Und jetzt wollte ich ganz kurz mal darauf eingehen. Fällt Ihnen selbst auf, was man da hätte besser machen? Also es geht jetzt wirklich nur um konstruktives Feedback. Ist Ihnen was jetzt auf den ersten Blick aufgefallen, wo man vielleicht was verbessern kann? Ja, zum einen habe ich ja mal diese Servietung mit dem Hals. Die hat man da jetzt, hat man gesehen, habe ich den Knoten ein bisschen gelöst, weil das war auch ein langer Flug, deswegen habe ich das ein bisschen gelöst. Ja interessant, dass Sie es ansprechen, Sie haben ja den Knoten tatsächlich gelöst, um dann dieses eine kleine Mädchen, das im Weg stand, damit zu erdrosseln. Da wollte ich vielleicht nochmal reingehen, haben Sie da vielleicht eine Idee, wie man da, wie man es einfach irgendwie den Komfort für die Passagiere verbessern kann? Aber man sagt, man soll erst sich helfen und dann den Kindern. Und das war das Kind halt im Weg. Aber da ich mir ja selber erstmal helfen sollte, das Flugzeug zu verlassen, habe ich das Kind dann erstmal in dem Moment halt ja erdrosselt. Und im Nachhinein hätte man ihm ja noch helfen können, da war es dann aber leider ja zu schwer. Wir schauen mal ein bisschen vor, hier brechen sie jetzt in das Cockpit ein und reissen den Piloten von seinem Sitz und packen den Steuerungsknüppel. Nicht zu vergessen mit den Worten, das kriege ich besser ja selber hin als sie. Ja, richtig. Was ja dann tatsächlich nicht so passiert ist. Ich habe mich ein bisschen überschätzt. Ich habe diesen Flugsimulator X, wo man irgendwann aufgehört hat, auch da ist es 2008, 2009, dann irgendwann kam X. Da dachte ich mir, wenn ich da ger gerufen bin drin und so Level 10 erreicht habe, dann kann ich auch eine Boeing 747 einfach auch herlanden.
Ich ziehe das Video mal in die Dropbox, sie gucken es einfach selber nochmal an, aber ansonsten einfach toi toi toi für den nächsten Flug. Dankeschön. Das wird schon. Vielen Dank. Hast du mitbekommen, dass das Flugzeug, der letzte Flug von Air Berlin, dass sie so ein crazy Manöver über Düsseldorf gemacht haben?
Kein Looping, aber fast, aber auch nicht, es ist so lang, leicht anders geflogen als die meisten Flugzeuge, so nah am Tower vorbei, aber auch nicht so richtig nah, aber Leute haben standen davor so Planespotter, die dachten so, oh mein Gott, und da war auch aus dem Tower hat man Leute gehört, die gesagt haben, ja wow, wir haben es gerade gesehen, die mit dem Captain gesprochen haben, wir haben es gesehen, ganz, ganz toll, man denkt sich so, ja, war das so toll, er ist einfach ein bisschen im Kreis geflogen über Düsseldorf und dann haben sich Leute beschwert, ganz toll. Aber sind alle Piloten jetzt raus oder was? Oder können die einfach bei woanders mitfliegen? Ja, die werden dann einfach jetzt schön zu TUI Fly geholt und dann ist ja gut, oder Lufthansa. Ich glaube, die haben... Aber ich meine, es müssen ja immer noch genauso viele Leute fliegen, also es braucht ja genauso viele Flugzeuge, also müssen die ja einfach woanders unterkommen. Es werden jetzt nicht einfach weniger Leute fliegen, weil eine eine Firma pleite gegangen ist, oder? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Das ist ein guter Punkt, es müssen doch genauso viele Leute fliegen. Also sollte eigentlich niemand seinen Job verlieren dürfen. Ja, das war den Leuten, die jetzt am Arbeitsmarkt kämpfen und weinen und ihre Familien ernähren müssen. Wenn ihr einen weinenden Air Berlin-Mitarbeiter seht, gebt ihm ein USB-Stick mit dieser Podcast-UFO-Folge drauf und hört ihn an und er wird merken, es ist völlig unbegründet, völlig unlogisch, dass er gerade keinen Job hat. Ist ja auch nicht schlecht. Er ist nicht nur traurig, sondern auch wütend dann im Anschluss. Zählen jetzt eigentlich Air Berlin-Mitarbeiter zu ausgestorbenen Tierarten? Oh! Wieder beim Thema, ja. Und wenn die wieder gefunden werden, dann... Warum dann Lazarus-Effekt jetzt? Weil tatsächlich habe ich auch recherchiert. Man hat ja so Jesus' greatest hits auf dem Schirm, ne, auf Wasser laufen, weinen, Blinder heilen, was viele vergessen. Jesus hat auch mal in so einem Nebensatz einfach einen Mensch von den Toten wieder auferstehen lassen. Ja. Ist es tatsächlich so? Und der Typ hieß Lazarus. Und deswegen Lazarus von den Toten auferstanden. Aber dass man das so überspringt.
Aber ich fände einfach interessant, ob es irgendwann mal auch Tiere gibt, die dann wieder ausgestorben gelten, dann wieder gefunden werden, wieder ausstellen. So eine On-Off-Tierart. Spitzmaus, wo man so sagt, so Leute, wir machen was jetzt, was machen wir jetzt? Enwär ihr sterbt alle, gebt mal rechts. Alle, die sterben wollen, gebt mal jetzt rechts r. Die fucking Moskauer Spitzmaus, seit 120 Jahren, alle drei Jahre, oh, ich bin da, immer wieder ausgestorben. Ey, es gibt dann diese Heuschreckenart, die alle vier Jahre schlüpft, wo immer so eine Plage entsteht, die immer nur alle vier Jahre, weil der Zyklus so seltsam ist. Nee, nee, nee, nee, die leben jedes Jahr, aber durch deren Zyklus, wie die sich vermehren, entsteht so eine komische mathematische Formel, dass sie alle vier Jahre eine Plage haben.
Alle vier Jahre gibt es irgendwo in so einem Land, Australien, das ist ja das Land der crazy Tierarten, aber die haben dann so eine Heuschreckenplage, weil da genau dann die Anzahl der Männchen und Weibchen so ist, dass da, lest das mal nach, ist spannend, kann man irgendwo nachlesen.
Ja.
Nochmal, zurück zu den Flugzeugen.
Wir machen immer heute Lazarus-Effekt ein bisschen. Ein bisschen Flugzeuge. Genau, ein bisschen das, damit ihr es drauf habt, und dann geht es um Flugzeug. Ja. Genau, Flugzeuge, meine Frage, schliessen die die ab? Also, angenommen, weil zum Mal haben die dann auch gesagt, ja, da hat jemand gefragt, und wie lange bleiben Sie jetzt hier in diesem Paradies? Und dann hat die Stewardess gesagt, ach, wir fliegen übermorgen wieder nach Hause. Okay, übermor fangen Sie nach Hause. Okay, heisst das Flugzeug steht da jetzt zwei Tage lang rum, weil es fliegt ja jetzt niemand wieder zurück. Oder eine andere Crew, weiß ich nicht, rettet sich aber nicht. Ich glaube, die werden einfach alle für zwei Tage da untergebracht und fliegen dann gemeinsam wieder zurück. Ich glaube nicht, dass ein Flugzeug einen Tag lang rumsteht. Aber es gibt ja auch so Hallen an Flugzeugen und so. Ja, aber die verdienen doch Geld damit. Aber nur mal rein hypothetisch, es bleibt stehen. Wir schliessen das dann ab.
Was meinst du, so ein Schloss?
Wir haben dann so ein Fahrwerk, dann in so einem Schloss, an so einem Boller. So eine Fahrradkette. So ein Zahlenschloss. Die Zahl ist fünf, fünf, eins, fünf, nicht weiter sagen. Und Passagier aus G3 plötzlich. Und da kommen mir so Leute angeschlichen, die einen daran rumfummeln und sagen, hau ab, hau ab, ksch, ksch, weg jetzt!
Dafür gibt es dann diese Fahrzeuge, die Vögel und die Diebe verscheuchen. So wegschieben mit so einem Flug. Am Flughafen gibt es für alles ein Fahrzeug. Aber das ist doch geil, weil ich denke mir, die haben dann so einen allgemeinen Schlüssel halt, wo die dann so bippippipp und dann blinkt der kurz und dann ist doch gut. Und dann fahren die Spiegel so ein auch.
Was ist denn das? Wie schließt man das ab? Haben die so einen Schlüssel?
Aber du kommst ja da auch gar nicht hoch. Du brauchst ja so ein Treppenauto, um da überhaupt erstmal hochzukommen.
Ich wette, die sind nicht abgeschlossen einfach. Du kannst in jedes Flugzeug einfach reingehen. Der Hangar ist abgeschlossen oder so. Hangar. Hangar, Hangar, der ist abgeschlossen. Hangar, Hangar, Hangar, Hangar!
Es gibt gleich was zu essen. Hangar Games. Kontor?
Ja, wir sind nie zu Hause in dem Flugzeug, in der Aeronautik. Aber apropos, wir wissen nicht, was wir da haben. Also es gab mal, hat mir jemand angefangen bei Pupopedia mit einem Transkript. Ich fahre mir auf die Stelle, Hangar, Hangar, Hangar, Hangar, Hangar, Hangar, Kontor, Fragezeichen. Und dann, wenn jemand irgendwann über uns einen Artikel schreibt, dann möchte ich, dass ihr das Rauschen nehmt als Transkript. Wir haben uns ja in der letzten Folge gefragt, was sind Lagunen, was ist ein Golf, was ist eine Bucht, wir hatten keine Ahnung. Und das Tolle darin ist, unsere geniale Community hat es natürlich mal wieder geschafft, uns aufzuklären, und zwar mit dem perfekten Video. Es gibt genau das Video, das genau alles erklärt, was in Gewässer wird. Hey, Stefan und Florentin an beide Begriffe. Hatte schon 800.000 Klicks, wir wissen nicht warum, aber das ist so geil. Nicht nur findest du im Internet die Antwort, nee, du findest auch genau das richtige die lösung für genau dein problem
mir ist mir aufgefallen dass die meisten fragen bei gute frage punkt net nicht gut sind das möchte ich nur mal kurz sagen mittelmässige ich finde die meisten ja mittelmässige fragen punkt net semi gute fragen punkt net weiß ich nicht aber wo wir gerade bei Schlössern waren. Vox, aber es hat mit beiden nichts zu tun. Vox, die machen so verschiedene Erklärvideos zur gesellschaftlichen Themen. Schaut mal VOX auf YouTube, guckt mal mal an. Aber interessant. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, es gibt auch glaube ich sogar ein Vox-Video, ob man Flugzeuge abschliessen kann oder so, habe ich mal gesehen. Hundertprozentig. Und da wird erklärt, was das alles ist. Ich weiß, was eine Lagune ist, ich weiß, was eine Küste ist, ein Golf. Atoll wurde nicht erklärt, das ist immer noch ein Mysterium. Aber ich glaube, ein Atoll ist sowas wie ein Berg unter Wasser. Vielleicht findet ihr auch mal raus, ob man ein Flugzeug abschliessen kann. Ich habe mich gefragt, bei Schlüsseln und Schlössern, warum man diesen, das verwirrt mich auch und das spart auch echt viel Zeit, wenn es das nicht gäbe, es gibt diesen Bonus-Turn. Also angenommen, meine Wohnungstür hast du zwei Turns, und dann gibt es noch so einen Bonus Bonusturn und dann kannst du den Schlüssel nicht rausziehen.
Dann musst du ihn wieder halb umdrehen, weißt du, einmal quasi nicht ganz, sondern um 90 Grad, um 180 Grad drehen und dann kannst du ihn erst rausziehen.
Was ist denn das für ein Bonusturn? Bei Schlösser gibt es einen Bonusturn.
Du kannst ihn nicht nämlich nur abschliessen, weil du kannst ihn noch ein bisschen weiter drehen, dann kannst du den Schlüssel nicht rausziehen.
Was ist das für eine merkwürdige Zwischenwelt, die da plötzlich passiert? Ach so, du du meinst dann so Überhang, wenn man schon zweimal gedreht hat und dann noch weiter. Genau, ich habe es mit Bonus-Turn genannt. Wofür ist der denn gut? Das habe ich wirklich nicht verstanden. Ah ja, ich glaube, das ist vielleicht einfach technisch nicht machbar, dass man es dann nicht weiter drehen kann, oder? Weil da blockiert dann der Riegel, weil der schon so weit ist, wie es geht, der kann sich nicht mehr weiter bewegen. Aber wie oft ich dann schon mal denüssel wieder in die eigentlich Falschrichtung drehen musste, um es dann rauszuziehen. Ja, was ist denn da los? Ich habe mir letztens Schlösser kopieren lassen, und ich finde eines der unangenehmsten, also auch unter den Top Ten Awkward Gesprächen, ist, wenn dir jemand etwas komplett Sinnvolles, Vernünftiges und Kostengünstiges anbietet, du es aber ablehnst. Der meint dann so, ja, wir können hier kopieren, wir können aber auch, wir haben ja ganz neue Schlösser, die sind doppelt so einbruchsicher und es gibt ja in Deutschland immer mehr Einbrüche und das ist ja komplett leicht, es kostet nur 4,99 Euro. Aber ab dem Beginn des Satzes schon weh mehr mit dem Kopf gestüttelt. Genau, richtig und ich denke mir so, nee, nee, alles gut, alles okay, wunderbar, nee, und genau, es kostet sie gar nichts, sie kriegen noch 10 Euro obendrauf und ihr Haus ist sicherer, Nee, möchte ich eigentlich nicht. Wir kommen kostenlos bei Ihnen vorbei, bauen das ein, Sie kriegen die Cola. Wir haben noch diese Aktion, dass der ganze Laden an Ihnen gehören wird. Der ganze Laden und eine Million Dollar. Nee, danke. Wie gesagt, es kostet Sie nichts, aber Sie sind sicher gegen Einbrüche. Nee, nee, einfach nicht. Arbeit vielleicht, weiß ich nicht. Und der andere so, ach komm ey, es geht hier um ihr Leben, um alles, was sie besitzen. Sie können ermordet werden im Schlaf, ihr Computer wird geklaut, alles. Er kümmert sich mehr um dein Leben als du selber, er sorgt sich auch um dich. Ja, total. Aber was du hast ja erzählt hast, dass du nur dich im Schlüssel und hast nachmachen lassen und es ging lächerlich schnell, es ging kriminell schnell. Nee, bei mir hat es eine halbe Stunde gedauert. Ich glaube, es war eine Bekannte von mir, die wollte sich Schlüssel kopieren lassen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein awkward Gespräch, weil man weiß, irgendwas ist schiefgelaufen. Also da muss eine Kausalkette instandegekommen sein, an deren Ende nichts Gutes kann passieren, wo man dann Schlüssel nachmachen muss. Können Sie bitte diesen Schlüssel nachmachen? Das ist glaube ich dann so ein, du gehst so ein Bund ein mit, irgendwer von uns macht gerade illegalen Scheiß. Und die dürfen das dann einfach machen und dann hat sie gesagt, muss ich irgendwie meine Adresse geben oder so? Nö, nö, nö, ich mache das einfach. Ja, das war bei mir auch so, wo ich mir auch dachte, muss man dann, komme ich in zwei Tagen vorbei? Nee, in zehn Minuten ist es fertig. Wo man auch denkt, okay, das ist schon interessant, das ist schon sehr, sehr schnell geht das dann. Es ist tatsächlich kein Problem, wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, jemanden bittet, dich auf sein Haus aufzupassen. Kannst du einfach einen Schlüssel kopieren oder sowas? Es ist diese merkwürdige, ich glaube, der Gesetzgeber geht davon aus, dass wenn du einen Schlüssel hast, du auch den berechtigterweise hast. Ich glaube nicht, dass ein geklauten, wenn du den erstmal geklaut hast, ist das Nachmachen glaube ich nicht mehr verboten, weil die sagen, Props, du hast es geschafft, den zu klauen, aber jetzt genau wie man darf ja ausbrechen aus dem Gefängnis, dass er keine Straftat, weil die sagen, das ist schon okay. Ich glaube, viele kriminelle Dinge sind nicht so schwer, aber ich denke auch zum Beispiel, wie willst du denn beweisen, dass der Schlüssel ist? Weil angenommen, du hast einen Schlüssel geklaut und dann nimmst du halt einfach die Dokumente von deinem eigenen Haustürschlüssel mit und steht dann in den Dokumenten genau drin, wie der Schlüssel aussieht und ist der dann so eingezeichnet, so die Zacken. Weil sonst kannst du einfach dein eigenes Dokument mitnehmen und den geklauten Schlüssel und gibt es dann eine Möglichkeit, die Dokumente und den Schlüssel zu verbinden oder wie läuft das denn?
Ich verstehe auch nicht diese Ausweispflicht, weil jetzt habe ich halt einen Ausweis bei mir und aber das kann ja auch geklauen. Ja, aber da ist ja ein Bild drauf. Ja, und eine Unterschrift. Das ist schon ein ganz schön gutes System. Verdammt nochmal! Die haben es auch geschafft. Die haben es wirklich drauf. Ey, also der Zeit zurückgehen und dann das Gesetz ein Gesetzbuch schreiben. Das ist schon cool. Du musst an alles denken. Ach so, du bist jetzt im Mittelalter und du machst jetzt irgendwie Steuerreformen. Ja, aber auch Steuergesetze. Nach der Beimache der Republik mussten die auch sagen, gut, jetzt machen wir es mal vernünftig, Leute. Wir sind mit unserer Fusch-Taktik nicht so durchgekommen. Jetzt setzen wir es mal hin und machen das vernünftiges Gesetz, Verfassung, und dann haben sie sich hingesetzt und das angefangen. Das ist echt spannend, so eine Umbruchsstimmung, so ein, man macht jetzt neue Feiertage, man macht ein neues Gesetz, so, das ist auch so. Ja, auch in der Staatsform, so, weil die haben ja gesagt, wir müssen daraus lernen, Notstandsgesetze sind für den Arsch, alles klar, aber auch ein Mehrparteiensystem und dann wählt man so und so, alle haben eine Erststimme und eine Zweitstimme und da gab es bestimmt coole Diskussionen. Und da standen bestimmt noch ganz andere, abstruse Ideen. Die entscheiden das in einem Jahr und das ist dann für hundert Jahre gültig, einfach so für immer. Es ist irgendwie, man kann sich das nicht so gut vorstellen, dass sich jetzt nochmal alles grundlegend ändert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein Generationending ist, ob man aufwächst mit so einem Jahr, so wie es ist, ist es jetzt für immer. Aber ich glaube, wenn du in der DDR aufwächst oder so, da hast du dann nicht, weil es jetzt so schlecht ist oder so, aber eher so ein, wir machen jetzt so ein Gesellschaftsprojekt, so Sozialismus, wir verändern was, das ist hier historischer Umbruch. Und dann aber auch in Abgrenzung zum Kapitalismus im Westen hast du dann auch so ein, welches System wird sich durchsetzen, sind wir bald alle irgendwie Kommunisten oder nicht. Aber mittlerweile ist es so, man kann sich, hat gar keine Angst, dass es irgendwie eingegroovt. Es hat sich so ein bisschen eingegroovt. Es hat sich eingegroovt, alle haben sich so verständigt, so wird schon irgendwie bleiben. Es passt ja auch so. Manchmal sehnt man sich aber auch so ein bisschen nach Veränderungen, oder? Also ich finde Neues immer besser, Neues gut. Ja, mal so einfach mal auswürfeln oder mal Anarchie so für einen Monat.
Purge.
Oder so eine eigene...
Eine Purge-Nacht, eine Nacht, wo alles erlaubt ist. Das ist schon eine coole Prämisse.
Gab es mal ein Land, wo man es gemacht hat?
Naja, aber das ist doch doof, dann brichst du da in einen Laden ein und dann steht der Ladenbesitzer da und der so, Leute, kann ihr bitte nicht.
Und er so, nein, heute ist Purge! Und er so, ja, okay, aber das ist meine Eismaschine, muss ich morgen halt auch wieder reparieren. Ich sage, Leute, bitte, komm. Vor allem, ich graue die Problematik aber auch nicht ganz, weil die machen das ja, damit alle weniger morden. Ja. Damit den Rest des Jahres das sicherer ist. Ist das so. Wenn man einmal mordet, hat er dann sagt, gut passt, ich habe gemordet. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Ich glaube, gerade dann brichst du eine Mauer ein, weil du bringst dann, die Hemmschwelle sinkt ja dann. Oder nächstes Jahr musst du dann zwei umbringen. Oder wirst du umgebracht. Ja, what? Dann ist alles verloren. Ja, es ist, glaube ich, auch nur ein Film. Zwei, drei Filme, glaube ich. Es sind nur drei Filme. Es gibt dem Ganzen mehr Gewicht ein Argument gerade, Stefan. Die müssen noch die Emojis machen. Wir müssen die Emojis machen. Wir haben auch schon viele gute Vorschläge bekommen von anderen Leuten. Zum Teil bessere. Machen wir so eine Sammelklage einfach. Wir sammeln die alle. Ich glaube, das ist sowieso nur einmal im Jahr, dass sie das entscheiden, welche neuen Emojis es gibt. Wer war denn eigentlich? Puh, das weiss ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Farben, dachte ich, es gibt ja verschiedene Farben, aber nur als Kreise, ne? Du meinst den klassischen Dreieck? Ich meine Quadrat, alle Farben, also ein Spektrum, so 27 Gang Farben, und dann kannst du ja so Pixelart mässig Bilder malen. Wenn du halt so, du hast jede farbe einmal so als ein pixel und dann kannst du halt dann so ein kleines hühnchen kannst du dann so halt da muss er dann immer so umbruch und dann auf dem anderen auf dem nokia hände wird es anders eigentlich da müssen die kleiner sein ja aber du kannst nie im modus haben eine fest vorgefertigte größe ja aber angenommen weil dann gehen dann nur eine reihe zusammen mal fünf quadrate und das kann man nicht kannst du damit nicht mitmalen. Wohingegen, wenn die kleiner wären, das wäre ein Zusatzgimmick, könntest du wirklich riesen Bilder malen. Wow. Einfach mal gelb, einfach so, dass du das irgendwie vielleicht auch so markieren kannst. Wann fliegen dir das erste Mal Emojis raus, wo man sagt so, brauchen wir drei Hühnchen? Wir haben Hühnchen von der Seite, Hühnchen von oben, Hühnchen close up.
Reicht nicht eins. Wir haben so Mugshots, wir haben Mugshots von Hühnchen, einmal rechts, einmal oben, einmal links. Ja, irgendwann übernimmt diese Agentur irgendjemand anderes und der sagt, Leute, wir haben viertausend Emojis. Jetzt irgendwie und dann alle, nein, der darf nicht gehen und dann jetzt sind alle Hühnchen raus, jetzt sind alle Pflanzen raus, es gibt zwanzig verschiedene Pflanzen. Ich habe gestern eine Serie gesehen, wo ein Mugshot gemacht wurde.
Und da musste sie nach rechts gucken, nach links gucken und nach oben gucken. Zeigen sie uns ihren Hals. Da denke ich mir, ist es wirklich so, dass man das macht? Und warum muss man nicht nach unten gucken? Und dann werden Leute geholt und dann an dem Hals Foto erkennen sie, ja, sie war es mit dem Hals, mit dem grossen Hals. Wenn ich dir hundert Bilder von hundert Helsen zeige, könntest du dein eigenes erkennen? Ernsthaft? Nein. Bartwuchs? Doch. Na okay, glatt rasiert. Hundert glatt rasierte Männerhälse und du sagst, welcher ist meiner? Ich glaube, ich könnte hier viele ausschliessen, aber ich könnte ihn nicht herausfinden. Was meint, ist deine Chance? Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du das hast? Zehn Prozent. Zehn Prozent zehn Prozent, ja, wenn ich fünfzig Gesichter zeige von Leuten, die sehr, die sehr ähnlich sind und du bist dabei, würdest du dich erkennen? Ich sage jetzt mal ganz überheblich ja, kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass ich in dieser bizarren japanischen Gameshow dann vor drei Gesichtern kopfkratzend stehe und sagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Die sind schon sehr ähnlich, du hast mich da glaube ich falsch verstanden. Man denkt schon, ich habe gestern so eine Bilderstrecke gesehen, wo Leute sich selber in Museen entdeckt haben. Also ihre Doppelgänger in Museen, das ist schon ziemlich lustig. Das ist ein Ulk. Manche sehen auch genauso aus, wo ich mich auch frage, sahen die aus, als sie ins Museum gegangen sind, oder haben die sich selber entdeckt, sind nochmal nach Hause gefahren, haben die das angezogen und dann haben sie für Reddit nochmal mitzuholen. Das stimmt. Einmal in so einer Bilderstrecke sein. Sind das denn wirklich lustige Menschen oder ist das eher so ein, oh guck mal, der sieht aus wie ich. Ist nicht der, der das Foto macht, der lustigere Mensch. Ich frag mich immer, wie lustig sind solche Menschen, weil du lachst herzlich drüber,
aber ist es denn
gerechtfertigt, oder ist es einfach nur,
also ist denen
bewusst, wie lustig das jetzt ist?
Oder denken die einfach, oh guck mal, der sieht
ja aus wie Harald, Harald, stell dich mal daneben,
Knipp, und eigentlich
der, der die alle zusammenstellt
und die nebeneinander packt,
diese Fotos, das ist dann eigentlich eher die Idee, oder? Oder nicht? Aber die müssen dementsprechend benannt werden. Haha, found my doppelganger in the museum. Doppelganger ist auch so ein Wort, wo ich irgendwann, ich habe das irgendwann relativ früh, als ich Englisch gelernt habe, gehört das Wort, dass es das gibt, Doppelgänger, und da dachte ich mir, gut, das ist eine sehr einfache Sprache. Well, I see the doppelgänger there at the baum, at the house, maus, alles ist die Strasse. Englisch ist einfach, da dachte ich mir, doppelgänger, kindergarten, you know, you're just pronouncing it differently. Das sind die gleichen Wörter. Aber warum, es wäre gut, wenn es die deutsche Wörter gäbe, die im Englischen eine andere Bedeutung haben. Dass du halt halt dann sagst Doppelgänger, aber das ist irgendwie Regenschirm. Und dann kommst du und denkst dir, das ist ja völlig verrückt. Verrückte Welt. Das stimmt, das ist verrückt. Das ist eine verrückte Welt. Das ist eine verrückte Welt. Sind wir für Österreich, was Amerika für England ist? Wir haben eine bisschen andere Sprache, aber jeder weiß. Wir sind das grössere Land, das erfolgreichere Land, das international wesentlich unbeliebtere Land. Ja, passt schon. Schon ein bisschen, ne? Ja. Oder ist Österreich so das Mexiko? Nee, die Türkei ist das Mexiko für Deutschland. Und Schweiz ist unser Kanada. Oh, wo alles gut ist. Stimmt. Aber die Kanada ist nicht so rassistisch, ne?
Na, wohl manche schon.
Italien ist unser Frankreich.
Nee, ich glaube, Frankreich ist unser Frankreich.
Oder Brasilien ist deren Frankreich.
Ja.
Andere Kulturen.
Wir müssen die Karte, glaube ich, nochmal komplett neu zeichnen.
Einfach, es müssen gewissere Formen geben.
Stefan Tietze, ich finde, du bist ein toller Typ typ aber es gibt manche sachen die gefallen mir nicht an dir zum beispiel du bist einer der wenigen menschen die kaufen sich wasser mit geschmack wasser mit geschmack und ich weiß nicht was das soll manchmal sehe ich im supermarkt wasser mit geschmack und damit meine ich jetzt nicht irgendwie ein schaumwein im weitesten sind eine spreite sondern also ein wolweg ist nicht eine Cola auch Wasser mit Geschmack? Meine Frage. Ist nicht eine Sprite auch Wasser mit Geschmack? Nee, es ist ja halt so ein Hauch. Es ist so ein normales Wasser mit einem Hauch Pfirsich. Und nichts ärgert mich mehr als Heuche. Ich hasse Hauch. Es ist für mich, wenn ich Wasser trinke, und es gibt nichts Geileres als Wasser, wenn man richtig durstig ist, sind wir uns beide einig. Doch.
Nee, wenn ich richtig durstig bin, trinke ich lieber Wasser als zum Beispiel Cola. So einen schönen kalten Wodka. Okay, aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich nicht durstig bin, trinke ich lieber Cola als Wasser. So einen schönen kalten Gin. Ja, und deswegen glaube ich, ist das Wasser der beste Durstler. Ja, ist es schon. Also warum versuchst du, du mit deiner scheiß H2-Phobie zu sagen, ah, ich kann es besser als die Natur. H2. Du mit deiner scheiß Chemie-Chemie. So, jetzt wir hören einfach auf. Es wäre so ein guter Konter gewesen. 118 Folgen haben wir geschafft, jetzt wir hören einfach auf. Das war so ein, ah. Aber erklär dich mal, warum Kirsche hast du dich entschieden? Also, man muss dazu sagen, Wasser mit Geschmack ist, sind wir uns alle eigentlich uncool.
Wer auf diese Idee gekommen ist, furchtbar.
Ja, wer auf die Idee gekommen ist, zu kaufen.
Wolwig treibt das Ganze auf die Spitze. Das ist nämlich wirklich perfektioniert.
Erstmal, das Design ist toll. Du hast Wolwig, aber manchmal sagt Wasser mit Geschmack nicht, ich bin Wasser mit Geschmack.
Es hält nicht dieses Schild hoch, ich bin Wasser mit Geschmack.
Es hält nicht dieses Schild hoch, dieses leicht beschämende Schild. Aber das ist ganz selbstbewusst. Ganz groß ist dir drauf Kirchgeschmack. Dann hast du die ganze Nährstoffliste, ist in der Form einer Kirsche. Also alles daran sagt schon mal, ich bin Kirsche. Das ist schon mal gut. Die erste Regel von Wassers Geschmack, schäme dich nicht dafür, dass du Wasser mit Geschmack bist. Ja, und nenn es Wolvik Touch. Es heißt Wolvik Touch. Es hat aber, das ist ein bisschen ein anderes Statement, weil es hat schon mehr was von Kirschwasser als von Wasser mit ein bisschen Kirsche. Ich finde, Geroldsteiner Zitrone, sowas, die machen es falsch, weil da ist ganz wenig Zitrone. Da ist aber auch Polensäure drin, das ist was anderes. Ja, das ist nicht gut, das ist was ganz Absurdes.. Das ist halt sowas wie eine Limo-Schorle. Ja,
vielleicht. Ne, aber eine halbe, also ein Wasser mit Wasser mit Limo.
Eine Limo-Schorlen-Schorle.
Eine Limo-Schorlen-Schorle-Schorle.
Aber zum Beispiel, also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob du
zu den Menschen gehörst, die irgendwie dann so ein bisschen
sag ich mal Aversion haben
gegen, ah, das ist so chemisch und so
und das ist nicht natürlich. Ich finde aber,
wenn etwas klar ist und trotzdem einen Kirschgeschmack haben soll, ist es so offensichtlich, dass da irgendwas falsch läuft. Wenn es so ein bisschen rötlich wäre, wie so ein Fruchttee, würde ich sagen, okay. Aber so ist es so, was genau ist da drin? Selbst Kirschsirup ist rot. Meine Augen sagen, es ist auch so ein bisschen, das stimmt, das ist das einzige Problem, was es hat. Du hast das so gut erkannt. Es ist nämlich ganz klar. Ganz klar. Und man will es sehen. Man will Geschmack sehen. Und in dem Moment, wo ich durchgucken kann, denke ich mir, was haben die da jetzt gemacht genau? Was für eine chemische Bombe ist da drin geplatzt, dass es noch durchsichtig ist? Ich frage mich aber wirklich, was da drin ist, weil Tee verfärbt ja auch und ich meine, gibt es den Geschmack ohne Farbe, gibt es den einfach so Tröpfel zu rein, dann hat es einen anderen Geschmack. Ich glaube, es ist sogar weniger Chemie als ein wirklicher Kirschsaft, weil da machen die ein Rot rein mit Lebensmittelfarbe und sowas, damit es rot aussieht. Ich glaube, das ist sogar noch weniger verfärbt, fremde Dinge, weil der Geschmackstoff, glaube ich, einfach, den du reinpackst, einfach wirklich einfach farblos ist. Und ich glaube, aber ich will lieber mehr Chemie, damit es aussieht wie rote Farbe, als jetzt so. Ich verstehe nicht, wie man aus irgendwas Farbe rauskriegt. Ich verstehe, wie man eine Farbe zu einer anderen Farbe machen kann. Okay, aber irgendwas keine Farbe mehr anlassen? Ja. Lass uns mal ein Klärwerk, die grosse Klärwerk-Folge. Ja, da nimmst du ja was raus, aber da ist ja noch Kirsch mit drin. Trotzdem können wir gerne klären. Wir nennen sie Erklärwerk. Und da gehen wir rein und dann lassen wir uns mal erklären, wie das funktioniert. Tatsächlich, ich komme wieder darauf zurück, ich weiß, es ist langsam schon nervig. Oh, Flugzeuge. Leute regen sich dann auf. Nein, typisch Malediven. Oh, nein. Auf den Malediven haben die, es ist so anstrengend, quasi immer Wasser einzukaufen vom Festland, um Wasser hier rüber zu kutschieren. Und deswegen haben die mehr und machen mehr Wasser zu Trinkwasser. Nämlich, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert. Ich glaube, das Salz rauszubekommen ist sehr einfach, mit Wasser verdunsten lassen und so destillieren. Aber wie man dann die Nährstoffe, diese kleinen Bakterien und Plankton rausbekommt, das ist, ich noch schwieriger. Und da gehört auch zu, das ist ja nicht ganz klar, das ist nicht ganz klar, Meerwasser, das noch klar zu machen. Und das ist glaube ich ein typischer Klärberg-Berufteil. Also ich muss, ich habe das schon mal angesprochen, aber es ist ja immer so ein bisschen, man nennt ja Salz auch das weisse Gold, weil das früher mal so wertvoll war. Ich habe mich immer gewehrt gegen diesen Begriff, weil es gibt das Meer. Das heißt, jedes Land, das am Meer liegt, also zum Beispiel Italien, wie kann denn da Salz selten sein? Weil du hast überall ein Meer, aus dem du Salz gewinnen kannst. Jetzt sagst du, ja, aber Salz wurde ja auch in Salzwerken abgebaut, Bad Reichenhall, da haut man das aus dem Stein und dann so.
So weit wäre ich glaube ich nicht gegangen bei der Ausführung.
So was würdest du sagen, aber jetzt habe ich herausgefunden, dass als die zum Beispiel in konkret Bad Reichenhall in Bayern Salz abgebaut haben.
Salzburg.
Wie haben die das transportiert? Nicht als Salz, nee, als Salzwasser.
Die haben das in Wasser aufgelöst und haben dann die Sohle durch Leitungssysteme in eine andere Stadt gepumpt, weil das einfacher war, als irgendwie im Rucksack dein Trolli-Rucksack. Nee, schön Rohr voller Salz und dann pusten. Ja, so eine Leitung. Das heisst, selbst die, die Salz aus dem Berg gewonnen haben, lösen es dann nochmal auf in Wasser und haben damit Salzwasser wie Meerwasser. Also du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass das leichter ist. Aber die Natur hat euch bereits eine Leitung gebaut. Ja. Das Meer. Da ist schon Salzwasser drin. Und ihr aus Österreich müsst uns kein Meerwasser schicken. Ich war ja mal im Bad Reichenhall und hab da sogar gelernt, wie die das machen. Und ich dachte, die gehen da rein mit einem großen Hammer und hauen da das Salz aus der Wand. Nie, was die machen, die spülen den Berg mit Wasser aus! Um das Salz im Berg auszulösen. Und was rauskommt ist, Sohle ist Salzwasser. Und dann holen die da das Salz raus. Sohle ist Salzwasser? Ja, Sohle ist Salzwasser. Mehr ist Sohle? Ich geh kurz in die Sohle. Du gehst ins Meer, du scheiß Idiot. Ich lasse mein Kind. Ich hatte unser Sohn. Unser Sohn, wir hätten ihm nicht diese badreiche Haltdoku zeigen sollen. Oder das Podcast-Ufer hören lassen. Ich geh kurz, ich geh wacker in die Sohle. Ist es okay, Mama und Papa? Shut up! Just ... Ja, und deswegen ist das einfach Bullshit! Ja, das stimmt. Ich verstehe es nicht. Auch mit Öl. Öl ist überall! Wisst ihr, ich glaube nämlich, dass Öl auch nur die Sohle des richtigen Öls ist. Man holt das mit Wasser da raus. In Wahrheit ist Öl so ein Pulver. Oder mit Öl holt man Gas raus, dass man Wasser pumpt und das Wasser bindet das Gas zu Öl. Aber Öl akzeptiere ich. Es gibt grosse Ozeane voller Öl unter Wasser. Die liegen da und die pumpt man ab. Aber komm mir nicht mit Erdgas. Erdgas? Das muss doch hochsteigen. Du willst mir erzählen, dass es in der ganzen fucking Erdkruste nicht ein Loch gibt, wo das einfach entweicht?
Und dann kommt der Mensch und pumpt da, wo kommt das alles hin?
Wir hatten letztens einen Dreh und da war es kalt und dann hatten wir so eine Gasflasche und so ein Feuerding, wo das dann wärmisch war.
Wo habt ihr gedreht?
Wärmisch, hier drüben in der Halle und da war es kalt. Och, da muss man den Schauspieler eine Wärmedecke und einen Bunsenbrenner holen. Und ja, da gab es diesen Florentin Willis kalt, holt dem und er will den Kaviar, den guten Kaviar, nicht dem aus dem Rewe, den richtigen, den frischen. Dieser Wärmestrahler hat acht Stunden lang gewärmt mit Gas. Wo kommt das ganze Gas her? Weil das steigt doch aus. Du kannst ja nicht, also ist irgendwo in der Erde irgendwo ein riesiger Hohlraum mit Gas oder was? Was? Warum bricht das denn nicht ein, wenn das so große Mengen sind? Vielleicht ist das ja kein, ne, erstmal weil der Druck ja da ist, du hast ja Druck, viel Gas ist ja Druck. Ja, im Luftballon ist auch Druck, aber deswegen kann der trotzdem platzen. Nee, du hast von Einbrechen jetzt gesprochen, sorry. Warum es nicht einbricht, ist der Grund, weil Druck da ist. Weil es nicht entweicht, es kann einfach der Grund sein ... Ja, aber sorry, ganz kurz, dann kannst du ja sagen, ein Haus bricht auch ein, weil da Luftdruck herrscht in einem Haus. Wie viel da ... Wie viel Druck ist denn in so einem Erdgas?
Ich wollte nur sagen, ein Luftballon bricht ja auch nicht zusammen.
Sondern da ist Druck drin, deswegen wird das nur aussen gedruckt.
Ja, ein Haus bricht auch nicht zusammen, aber das hängt nicht an dem Luft, das im Haus ist.
Im Haus ist Luft.
Ja, aber kein Luftdruck.
Ja gut, aber ist denn in Erdgas Druck oder was?
Ich glaube schon, wenn du eine grosse Ansammlung hast und man war davon abgesehen, glaube ich, steigt Erdgas denn hoch? Weiß ich gar nicht. Vielleicht steigt es ja runter. Vielleicht ist es ein schwereres Gas als Sauerstoff zum Beispiel und deswegen bleibt es in der Erde. Nur meine Frage. Ich lasse mich mal kurz um deine Gedanken alleine. Ich glaube das nicht. Und warum ist da nicht mal ein Blitz eingeschlagen und es ist alles verbrannt? Also Erdgas finde ich Quatsch. Erdöl, das hält es zusammen und auch so Fracking und so, da musst du ja wirklich dir Mühe geben, um das aus dem Stein rauszukriegen, weil das halt dann so in kleinen, ganz kleinen Adern dann irgendwie. Bist du für oder gegen Fracking? Für Fracking. Ganz kleinen Adern dann so. Ich bin der einzige Mensch, der für Fracking ist. Niemand ist für Fracking. Ich bin tatsächlich die Person, die das mehr oder weniger alleine am Laufen hält, weil alle sagen entweder alle oder keiner. Ich glaube, der Typ, der auf die Idee gekommen ist, hat schon gesagt so, ich bin mir sicher, ich bin auch nicht so richtig dafür und es fühlt sich auch falsch an, das zu machen, ich habe da diese Idee, wo man in den Boden Löcher bohrt und bombt und wir sprengen das rein und holt dann da Erd, ich weiß, sorry, sorry, ich nehme schon zurück und irgendein Vollzug hat gesagt, alle waren dagegen, aber ein Typ hat gesagt, ja komm, lass mal machen. Das ist eine dumme Idee. Per Definition geht das schon schief. Ich meine, wir haben doch Erdöl im Meer, unter Meeresboden. Warum hat sich noch nie Erdöl mit dem Wasser vermischt, mit dem Meer? Wenn man da bohrt mit so einer BohrinselInsel, Boa, das verstehe ich jetzt auch erst, Boa-Insel, deswegen heissen die Boa-Insel. Ja, warum soll das Boa-Insel heißen? Die Erdkruste bohren. Warum ist es noch nie passiert, dass... Feuerzeug, jetzt verstehe ich es. Jetzt, ach jetzt, das Ficke mal. Schulranzen, jetzt habe ich es. Warum gab es nicht nie ein Erdbeben und so ein Erdöl-Reservoir ist komplett ins Meer geballert? Sag noch mal Reservoir. Reservoir. Wow. Warum ist es nicht komplett ... Warum hat sich noch nie das Meerwasser mit dem Erdöl vermischt? Weil das kriegst du ja nicht mehr sauber. Weil Öl und Wasser sich nicht vermischen. Das ist doch das erste Versuch, der man in Chemie macht. Ja, und deswegen ist es so ... Aber dann ist es auch kein Stress, dass BP irgendwie so ein Lecker hat. Ja, du denkst ja, hallo, neunt Klasse, Stefan sagt, ja, aber das vermischt sich nicht wie in meinem Salat. Ja. Da habe ich auch immer noch Öl. Halt die Fresse, Stefan. Mein Sohle-Salat. Gut, Stefan, dich nehmen wir nicht mehr mit auf den nächsten Ausflug ins Klärwerk. Oder, oder, warum gibt es nicht keine, das verstehe ich nicht, warum gibt es eine Ölsehung auf dem Meer?
Warum ist das Öl so safe in der Erde? Warum kommt es nicht raus? Es gibt Vulkane, es gibt Vulkane, da kommt Lava vom Erdmittelpunkt hoch an die Erde, warum geht denn nicht das Erdöl von seiner Erdkammer ins Meer? Das war die nebene Folge.
Hallo, hey, hey, wo sind denn alle?
Weg mit dem Abspann, weg mit dem Abspann, weg mit dem Abspann. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es passiert, Florentin, um dir kurz mal den Punkt zu nehmen. Ja, wo ist denn dann das große Ölsee auf dem Meer? Ich glaube, es passiert halt nicht in den Mengen, dass dann See entsteht, ein Ölsee. Außerdem kann ich mir auch das vorstellen. Weißt du, wie viel fucking Wasser ist gelaufen in der Welt? Weißt du, wie viel Wasser das da ist, wo du, natürlich gibt es ja mal Öl, dass da Öl austritt, aber doch nicht in den Mengen, dass das Wasser irgendwie, wie viel Prozent des Erdballs besteht aus Wasser? Richtig. 70? Viel. Keine Ahnung. Aber da tritt doch nicht so viel Öl aus, dass es wirklich ein Einfluss hat. Aber die müssen sich doch so viel anstrengen, diese ganzen Aktivisten, die irgendwie die Möwen sauber machen und so. Warum passiert sowas nicht natürlich? Weil ich meine, der Mensch, der bohrt ja nur ein ganz kleines Loch rein und saugt es dann heraus. Aber es ist tief, es ist viel tiefer. Aber als Natur kannst du doch ein Erdbeben. Es würde alleine niemals passieren. Vielleicht mal bei so einem Erdbeben, okay, aber wann passiert mal so ein grosses Erdbeben, dass es mal Auswirkungen hat, wenn nicht nur dramatische. Sorry, dass ich jetzt wirklich ganz kurz da dranbleibe, aber Erdöl ist doch nichts anderes als Dinosaurier. Es ist selbst mit mir anstrengend, ich höre nicht nur zu, ich rede auch dabei. Wie kommen denn Dinosaurier? Erstmal, das Meer ist wirklich fucking tief. Mir geht es genau wie euch, ich spüre es. Das Meer ist fucking tief und dann unter mir sind noch Dinosaurier, die sich verwandelt haben zu Öl. Wie geht das? War die Erde damals kleiner? Sie haben kein Sendebewusstsein. Mein Bewusstsein sagt mir sehr wohl, dass es gerade nicht unterhaltsam ist. Aber ich kann aktiv dagegen nichts tun. Fragen. Ja, ich stell einfach nur ein paar Fragen in den Raum, ein paar unbequemme Fragen an die Erdkrustenforscher da draußen, die auch gar nichts tun, die in ihren geologischen Instituten rumsitzen und nichts tun, weil sich kein ... Ja, er redet noch von Erdöl. Kein Mensch interessiert sich dafür. Die können doch in ihren Instituten machen, was sie wollen. Die sitzen da rum und sagen, hier Robin, Saphir, Lapislazuli und denken sich irgendwelche Nummern aus. Aber im Grunde, dadurch, dass die Öffentlichkeit sich nicht für Gestein interessiert, können die Instituten machen, was sie wollen. Hier sind 500 Euro. BP hat eben angerufen. Du sollst einfach nicht mehr von der Öhe reden.
Okay, du hast unbequeme Fragen gestellt.
Alter, mich nervt es so, wenn ich im ICE sitze und der vor mir macht die Lehne nach hinten.
Hallo?
Ich dachte mir, Alter, wie nervig ist das denn?
Weil ich will ja fahren mit dem Zug.
Wie viel habe ich mir gegeben?
Ich habe mir da auch ein Ticket gekauft.
150?
Und dann fahre ich da hin und dann lehnt er sich rein.
Ich lehne mich doch auch nicht einfach so.
Das war die Bahn.
150 Euro.
Die Bahn ist knickereg.
Alter, wie scheiße siehst du eigentlich aus heute, Stefan?
Hast du einen dummen Scheisspullover an, kommst du mit einer Hose, soll das Gürtel
sein oder was?
Das sind Fünfer.
Was zockst du gerne? Zockst du gerne, hast du einen Spieltipp für uns? Ja, mein Spieltipp war ja mal, dass du immer quasi das Doppelte setzt auf die Zahl. Das ist kein Spieltipp. Das ist Mathematik. Du hast jetzt eine Gaming-Sendung bei Rocket Beans TV und das ist kein Gaming. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Roulette Tourette. Wir haben heute einen ganz besonderen Tipp vorgelegt und zwar, wie man
beim Roulette sicher gewinnt. Ich weiß,
das war auch schon der Inhalt der Sendung
eins bis acht, aber heute
bei der neunten Sendung wollen wir das Rätsel endlich mal
zu Ende bringen. Also, wenn ihr Geld habt,
sagen wir mal, ihr habt zehn Euro, dann setzt ihr
erstmal ein Euro auf schwarz, kommt
schwarz dran, wechselt ihr die Farbe
und beginnt wieder erneut mit einem Euro auf rot. Wenn ihr verliert, wenn ihr verliert, dann müsst ihr das Doppelte auf diese Farbe setzen. Wenn ihr also verliert mit schwarz, ein Euro auf schwarz, macht ihr zwei Euro auf schwarz. Irgendwann werdet ihr gewinnen und ihr werdet den ganzen Verlust, den ihr davor hattet, wieder zurückgewinnen. So, das waren also zusammengefasste Sendungen 1 bis 8. Heute beim Staffelfinale möchte ich euch aber noch leider mit auf den Weg geben, dass sich die Banken darüber bewusst sind, die Casinobanken, und deswegen haben sie die Null und die Doppel-Null hinzugefügt, sodass dieses System nicht aufgeht. Danke, das war es von mir, das war Tourette Roulette. Bis vielen Dank. Ciao. Ciao. Ohne Null wird es nicht funktionieren. Ciao. Hallo? Wie abgesetzt? Wie, das war alles falsch. Wie kein Geld mehr. Gibt's einen Spieltipp? Hm, Karten zählen. Ist Karten zählen, hast du einen Film? Nee, ich mein jetzt eher sowas wie Gaming, Videospiele, nicht so, wie hoch kann ich den Stock in meinem Garten werfen, was du den ganzen Tag spielst, Stefan. Ich habe als Kind immer gespielt, wie hoch kann ich den Ball an die Decke werfen, ohne dass sie die Decke berührt. Hey, das ist mein Spiel. Nee, du hast leise Ball. Leise Ball, Grenzball, das ist Grenzball. Grenzball? Grenzball. Nein, das ist Deckenball. Nein, Grenzball, wie nah man das an die Decke werfen kann. Und ich war so oft Weltmeister von Deckenball. Und die Kommentatoren war ich meistens auch selber, die konnten nicht fassen, dass Tietze schon wieder den Titel geholt hat. Ich habe meine halbe Jugend auf dem Rücken verbracht und immer Bälle hoch an die Gegend die Decke geholfen. Tietze hat schon wieder im Deckenball, selbst die Kommentatoren, die ich selber war, waren irgendwann schon gelangweilt von der Schuhe. Irgendwann so, ja mein Gott, es spielt dann auch nur einer mit. Natürlich hat er gewonnen. Aber das war tatsächlich, ich habe in Berlin gewohnt und wir hatten so eine Berliner Wohnung, wo die Decken wahnsinnig hoch waren. Ich glaube, es waren vier Meter, also wirklich lächerlich hoch, einfach so, ihr baut zwei Wohnungen rein, lächerlich hoch. Und das war so geil, da im Bett zu liegen und dann einfach gute dreieinhalb Meter, der dann so richtig lang in der Luft bleibt und mit so richtig Kavems wieder nach unten kommt. Und nach zwei Wochen wieder zurückkommen endlich. Und das war, und ich ziehe nach Berlin, oh geil, Berghain, feiern, Drogen und ich so, alter, Berlin, meine City. Die decken sie doch. Das haben wir in Berlin erlebt. Tatsächlich ist es ein Spiel, das man sich ausdenkt als Zweijähriger, dann bis dahin cool, bis dann ein Kumpel kommt, irgendwie ein Kindergartenfreund, und man zeigt ihm das Spiel und der ist sofort besser und man hat aber immer sich selber kommentiert und war immer der Weltmeister und dann denkt man so, jopp, dann bin ich jetzt nicht mehr der Weltmeister. Ey, der zweite Mensch, der je gesungen hat, der erste Mensch, der singt, der denkt, ich bin fucking Genie und der zweite, laaa und der erste so, ah fuck. Und dann der erste Mensch, der mit Vibrato singt und also what, was ist das für next level shit? Oh say can you see, by the dawn's early, like lead, ye, ye. Nee! Hast du ein Vibrato, wenn du schön einen Ton singst?
Nee, aber beim Instrument sagt man Tremolo, ne?
Nee.
Und beim Singen Vibrato, oder was?
Tremolo sind zwischen zwei Tönen.
Ah, und Vibrato ist, wenn du ein...
Ich glaube nicht genau zwischen zwei Tönen.
Ich glaube, Tremolo, wenn du bei der Gitarre oder beim Klavier einzelne Tasten hast, dann ist es Tremolo,
aber wenn du einen flexiblen Notenton hast, dann ist es ein Vibrato.
Nein, das ist ein Glissando.
Nein, Glissando ist ...
Ey, unser Podcast-Über-Outro ist ein Glissando.
Ist am Ende immer ein Glissando.
Toll, Glissando.
Ein Glissando, Tremolo, er bett auch ein Bucco.
Ja, Musik.
Ja, Italienisch, schreiben die immer. gemacht habe, habe ich schon unendlich mehr Töne erzeugt, als du erzeugen kannst mit dem Klavier. Weil du ja allem der Weltmöglichen zwischen, auch zwischen eins und zwei, sind ja unendlich viele Zahlen. Natürlich. Also hast du auch zwischen dem Ton C und dem Ton Cis hast du unendlich viele Zwischentönen, die du alle triffst. Dass du irgendwann die Wellenlänge nicht mehr, also so wie du keine Ahnung, so dieses, also du kannst ja Energie auch nicht beliebig klein machen, sondern es gibt ja so ein kleinstes Teilchen. Und vielleicht lässt sich das auf Wellenlänge auch irgendwo anwenden. Und auf die Mathematik, genau. Auf die Mathematik eben nicht, weil sie ja theoretisch ist, aber praktisch, physikalisch. Er hat so dieses Grinsen im ... Er hat dieses ... Ihr müsst es eben. Er hat dieses unsympathische Grinsen im Gesicht, dass er das weiss. Jeder kann sich das vorstellen. Wow. Jeder kann sich das vorstellen. Mathematik ist ja rein theoretisch. Ich mag es einfach nicht, wenn du den Begriff unendlich verwendest, da bin ich sehr empfindlich. Es gibt dich genau diesen Bullshit-Labern noch unendlich mal weiter im Universum. Unendlich mal Florentin, der diesen Bullshit sagt. Der meint, er müsste
mir sagen, dass ich ihn unendlich nicht mehr benutzen soll.
Wie geht's weiter eigentlich?
Wie geht's weiter mit dem Podcast-Ufo?
Also, Podcast-Ufo macht bald eine
fünfjährige Pause.
Eine fünfjährige Halloween-Pause.
Happy Halloween!
Nichts mehr für fünf Jahre.
Und dann dann wieder auftauen, als wäre es nichts gewesen,
als wäre es das normalste der Welt. Wir machen normal weiter. Wir reden immer noch über die Malediven, warum auch immer. Naja, ich glaube, wir machen bald, also, wir machen live. Kochen. Wir kochen live für euch einmal. Ich würde sagen, Weihnachten machen wir mal so zusammen Plätzchen backen, Spekulatius backen. Gerne, Plätzchen. Und dann der Live-Auftritt mit dem kleinsten Publikum der Welt, zwei Leute. Genau, die kriegen aber auch ein bisschen Kekse. Einer kommt nicht davon. Er ist krank. Ja. Bist du Plätzchen backen? Nee, nee, ich war auch eher, Vanillehörnchen fand ich immer toll. Nee, Kupferl. Ich hatte immer Zitronen, ich hatte so Zitronen, die dann zur Hälfte in so eine dunkle Kuvertüre eingetunkt waren. Und dann wollte ich die immer Leuten geben, ich war kein Kind mehr, glaube ich, aber ich war schon noch so jung. Und dann habe ich die immer Leuten gegeben und die immer so, das ist aber nicht wirklich weihnachtlich. Ich will meinen Zitronenkeks mit Glasur wieder wie ich sage, ja scheiß da drauf, ist einfach Zitronenkekse.
Also die haben das auch nicht negativ gemeint, sondern nur, oh, wie kommst du da jetzt drauf?
Wenn man zu Weihnachten am 24. Dezember einen Snickers jemandem schenkt und man so, okay, das ist jetzt nicht wirklich angemessen, aber gut, danke.
Unabhängig davon, was macht dieser fremde Junge genau an Weihnachten abends bei uns in der Wohnung?
Verkauft ihr Kekse war strange. Und die meisten davon sind angebissen, auch komische Sache. Aber ich glaube, du hättest einfach cheaten können, indem du die Form weihnachtlich machst. Mit Sternen und Sternschnuppen, viel Sternen. Aber wenn du in Sternen reinweist, erwartest du nicht Zitrone. Das ist ein Schock, das ist ein Geschmacksschock. Ja? Geh schon. Klar, weil du nicht mit Zitrone rechnest. Du rechnest mit... Aber Apfel ist nicht weihnachtlich, Bratapfel ist weihnachtlich, Zitrone nicht Bratzitrone. Heisse Zitrone schon weihnachtlich. Ich finde das ganz gut, weil Feiertage, manchmal denkt man sich ja, Feiertage sind überholt, christlich, religiös braucht man nicht mehr. Aber auf der anderen Seite, zum Beispiel habe ich so einen Thread gelesen auf Reddit, warum denn zu Weihnachten Zimt beliebt ist. Weil Zimt hat ja gar nichts mit Weihnachten zu tun, es kommt irgendwo aus dem Urwald, wahnsinnig weit weg, wird einmal um die halbe Welt geschifft. Warum denn Wein... In Wasser, Leute! Jetzt reicht's! Jetzt reicht's! Warum machen die Zohle aus Zimt? Zimtzole! Was soll das? Und der Historiker hat halt gesagt, naja, Gewürze waren halt früher sehr teuer und man konnte die sich halt nur einmal im Jahr leisten. Oh mein Gott! Ist das die beste Erklärung für eine vernünftige Frage? Und das war halt zu Weihnachten. Ja, klar. Und dann hat sich das halt etabliert, Zimt zu Weihnachten. Und irgendwann hat man das auch emotional damit verbunden. Aber allein weil es einen Feiertag gibt und weil es gewisse Dinge gibt, die selten sind, fügt man die automatisch zusammen und dadurch wird der Feiertag noch besonderer, weil es der einzige Tag ist, an dem es Zimt gibt. Ich will noch mal ein paar Leute einladen. Ich will mal einladen, einen Pilot mich mal einladen, um herauszufinden, ob Dinge ... Ich weiss, es geht schnell durch diese Flugzeugphase. Leute, helft, helft!
Aber wenn der durchstartet, dann passieren schlimmere Dinge, als man denkt im Cockpit und so. Und wenn der diese Anschnallzeichen anmacht und, hallo, wir kriegen jetzt leichte Turbulenzen, da sind verschiedene Dinge. Unheil ist im Anschlug in Wirklichkeit. Und ich will die von Kamps einladen, weil Kamps meine ich nämlich, macht die Bäckereierei, die machen nämlich zu Weihnachten ins Laugenbrötchen Zimt. Da bin ich der festen Überzeugung, dass sie die Rezeptur ändern, aktiv. Echt, ohne das zu beschreiben? Genau wie ich der festen Überzeugung bin, dass Coca-Cola im Laufe des Jahres anders schmeckt. Ich glaube, dass zu Weihnachten schmeckt Coca-Cola ein bisschen anders. Und zu Weihnachten ist auch im Leitungswasser etwas Zimt. Ja, vielleicht ist im Leitungswasser ein bisschen in der Luft. Oder weil alle so viel mit Zimt backen, hat man jene Zeit so vielleicht einen Zimtgeruch durch die Welt schweben. Nee, ist Quatsch. Aber warum, ich verstehe nicht, Vanille ist ja so das Vorzeige langweilig. Man sagt ja auch, wenn was simpel ist, dann sagt man Vanilla. Aber Vanille ist doch mega selten. Also auch so, wenn du die echte Vanille kaufst, dann kostet die schon so fünf, fünf. Ich hätte gerne Vanille-Coke. Oh, boring. Nein, man sagt, wenn es verschiedene Varianten von etwas gibt, dann ist die Standardvariante Vanilla. Nur beim Eis. Zum Beispiel bei World of Warcraft sagt man auch, die erste Variante war Vanilla und danach kamen die Expansions, die Erweiterung. Aber das klassische Standardlangweilige ist Vanilla, weil es so simpel ist. Obwohl Vanille an sich was total selten und komplexes ist. Es ist nicht wahrscheinlich einfach, weil es weiss ist, oder? Es ist wahrscheinlich einfach, man sieht es und denkt sich in Stand Vanille und Zimt ist auch schon in einer Schublade bei mir gekommen. Passt das zusammen? Es hat diese Schoten, es hat diese Schotencharaktere. Oh, ich habe jetzt Bock auf Vanille. Gibt es so eine Vanillemilch? Ja, klar. Bei uns in der Schule damals gab es die Wahl zwischen Erdbeermilch, Vanillemilch, Kakao. Keine Banane? Nee, Banane gab es nicht. Oh. Das war eine komische Zeit. Und dann war morgens vom Klassend dran plötzlich so ein Kasten für alle Leute, ich hatte immer Kakao. Aber was für ein seltsames Konzept.
Aber es ist total merkelig, weil, also kann ich jetzt einfach eine Vanilleschote mir kaufen und die Vanille in Milch tun und dann habe ich Vanillemilch?
Weil zum Beispiel, es gibt ja manche Gewürze, die nicht so funktionieren.
Du kannst zum Beispiel einfach, keine Ahnung, Zucker tust du in Milch und dann hast du halt Zuckermilch.
Aber Zimt, wenn du in Milch tust, passiert da gar nichts. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es dann schmeckt wie Zimt. Die Leute von Kinderriegeln werden gerade mega nervös. Fuck, fuck, fuck, er hat es raus, er hat es rausgefunden, er hat es rausgefunden. Zimt löst sich ja nicht auf und überträgt den Geschmack ja auch nicht so. Das musst du dann erst wieder einbacken in Zimt hören. Fett ist ein Geschmacksträger.
Das stimmt.
Fett ist ein Geschmacksträger. Aber Milch ist ja Fett. Milch ist ja Fett drin.
Eine Bananenmilch kannst du ganz einfach machen. Du hast eine Banane, Milch stampfen dann. Aber Zimtmilch?
Vielleicht musst du dann...
Schwimmt dann oben die Haut.
Ja, deswegen ist Fett der Geschmacksträger, weil vielleicht dann das Fett und der Milch dann dazu führt, dass das Zimt besser, das wird besser
aufgenommen. Aber klappt Vanillemilch?
Einfach eine Vanilleschote auskratzen in Milch?
Weil das sind ja dann nur so einzelne schwarze Brocken.
Und die haben doch auf den
Geschmacksnäher fast gar keinen Einfluss.
Man müsste das ja irgendwie so machen,
dass es sich auflöst oder so.
Kennst du bei manchen Liedern, manche Lieder haben ein klares Ende, aber manche Lieder werden so langsam leiser. Ja, ja. Und ich glaube, das ist die erste Podcast-Urfolge, die so langsam leiser wird. Ja, ab Minute 40. Die so ganz langsam. Ey, das ist auch im Wege, das finde ich immer einen geilen Song, der wirklich ab zwei Sekunden schon immer ein bisschen langsamer, leiser wird immer. Und dann irgendwann so ganz leise noch zu hören ist. Ey, was ich, und das ist vielleicht nochmal eine extra Folge, aber was ich hasse ist, wenn gerade so bei modernen Elektro und so ein bisschen alternativ Elektro Sachen immer es manchmal so ein Intro gibt, wo Leute reden oder so, wo dann irgendwie so Samples, es gibt ja auch so oft Samples von Martin Luther King oder sowas und dann hört man immer, dass er, wer will das denn, ey? Und noch schlimmer sind Leute, die sich selber erwähnen.
Jason Nerula.
Ey, während der Beat und die Musik läuft,
kannst du sagen und machen, was du willst, mir scheißegal.
Aber gib mir nicht, bevor der Song losgeht.
Aber drop den fucking Bass!
Okay, macht's gut.
Bis nächste Woche, das war das Podcast-Ufo.
Wir machen mit einem Glissando.
Blablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablabl